>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
FOR FIVE FULL YEARS, THE
CAMPAIGN FOR PRESIDENT INTO HIS
TERM IN THE WHITE HOUSE,
DONALD TRUMP SAID OFTEN THAT HE
WANTED AMERICAN TROOPS TO LEAVE
AFGHANISTAN.
FINALLY COMING IN HIS LAST
MONTHS IN OFFICE, TRUMP SEEMED
TO ACT ON THIS PURITY TOLD AIDES
HE WOULD PULL THE TROOPS OUT.
THEN ON JUNE 26TH OF LAST YEAR
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STOPPED HIM
FROM DOING THAT.
THE TIMES WROTE A STORY SAYING
THE INTEL COMMUNITY HAD
"CONCLUDED THAT THE RUSSIAN
MILITARY INTELLIGENCE UNIT
SECRETLY OFFERED BOUNTIES TO
TALIBAN LINKED MILITANTS FOR
KILLING COALITION FORCES IN
AFGHANISTAN."
VLADIMIR PUTIN WAS MURDERING
AMERICAN SOLDIERS.
OBVIOUSLY, THERE WAS NO LEAVING
AFGHANISTAN NOW.
AND ANYONE SUGGESTING LEAVING
AFGHANISTAN WOULD BOW TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AS A MATTER OF PRINCIPLE,
AMERICAN TROOPS HAD TO STAY IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AND THEY DID STAY PEER THEY ARE
STILL THERE TODAY.
OFFICIAL WASHINGTON WENT BERSERK
OVER "THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY.
THOUGH THE PIECE CONTAINS NO
ACTUAL FACTS, CNN SENIOR
INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
DECLARED IT RICHLY REPORTED.
A RICH TAPESTRY OF REPORTING.
AND THE REST ARE THERE AGREED
WITH THIS.
THE TIMES STORY WAS
INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRMED BY MANY
OTHER OUTLETS NO ONE EXPLAIN
HOW INDEPENDENTLY CONFIRMED.
BUT THEY DIDN'T NEED TO BECAUSE
IT WAS DEFINITELY TRUE.
WE KNEW THAT.
THE STORY WAS REAL.
THE ONLY QUESTION WAS, WHY
HADN'T DONALD TRUMP ATTACKED
RUSSIA IN RETALIATION FOR THE
KILLING OF U.S. SOLDIERS?
THE WHITE HOUSE YET TO AUTHORIZE
ANY STEPS IN RESPONSE TO THIS
GRAVELY NOTED APPEARED SUDDENLY
IT WAS CLEAR WHO DONALD TRUMP
WAS REALLY WORKING FOR.
>> WE NEED TO LOOK AT THE REAL
THREAT TO U.S. TROOPS AND THE
RISK THAT RUSSIA IS PUTTING A
BOUNTY ON THEIR HEADS, NO MATTER
WHAT MEMOS MAY HAVE BEEN
IGNORED.
WHAT IS THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER
HERE?
WHERE DO WE HAVE TO FOCUS?
>> TO SAY NOTHING ABOUT PUTTING
BOUNTIES ON AMERICAN TROOPS.
>> IT IS UNBELIEVABLE, JOANNE.
HE IS YET TO SAY ANYTHING AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
ABOUT BOUNTIES ON AMERICAN
TROOPS.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT THE
FOURTH YEAR AS
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT INTEL IS?
IT IS ALL LEADS UNTIL THE
EXPLOSION UNTIL THE BOMBS GO OFF
IN THE ATTACKS HAPPEN.
THIS IS SOMETHING REALLY, REALLY
SCARY ABOUT HIS FUNDAMENTAL LACK
OF UNDERSTANDING ABOUT WHAT THE
INTELLIGENCE PRODUCT IS AND
DOES.
>> Tucker: HOW BAD IS IT?
DONALD TRUMP DOESN'T EVEN
BELIEVE HIS OWN INTELLIGENCE
AGENCIES.
THAT IS THE LADY WHO USED TO
FLECK JIM BUSH AND HIGHLY UPSET.
THAT IS REALLY SCARY, SHE SAID.
"THE WASHINGTON POST" THOUGHT
SO.
THE POST FACT-CHECKED OR GAVE
THE PRESIDENT FOUR PINOCCHIO'S
AND THAT IS BAD FOR THE TIME OF
NOT BELIEVING BLIND QUOTES IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
THE PREDICTABLE RAGE AVALANCHE
FOLLOWED "THE DAILY BEAST" AND
DECLARED IT A SCANDAL.
AND THEN ADAM SCHIFF, THE
RANKING MEMBER THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE REMINDED THIS COUNTRY
THAT UNNAMED SOURCES AND
LEFT-WING NEWSPAPERS ARE THE
"GOLD STANDARD" FOR WHAT IS
TRUE.
>> HE IS INVITING VLADIMIR PUTIN
TO WASHINGTON ALL THE WHILE THES
THIS CREDIBLE ALLOCATION OF
RUSSIANS PUTTING A BOUNTY ON
AMERICAN HEADS.
THAT TO ME IS DESPICABLE.
>> THIS IS NOT A HOAX.
THE FACT THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY IS STILL LOOKING FOR
ADDITIONAL EVIDENCE DOESN'T MAKE
IT A HOAX.
>> AMERICANS ARE OUTRAGED ABOUT
WHAT RUSSIA MAY BE DOING.
THE ONE PERSON WHO ISN'T
OUTRAGED IS DONALD TRUMP.
IT DOESN'T END UP IN THE
PRESIDENTIAL DAILY BRIEF IF IT
IS A HOAX.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY DOES
NOT ONLY PUT FOLKS IN THE DAILY
BRIEF BUT RATHER IT IS THE GOLD
STANDARD.
>> Tucker: SO IT DOESN'T WIND
UP IN THE PRESIDENT'S DAILY
BRIEF, IT IS A HOAX, OBVIOUSLY.
IT'S NOT LIKE WE INVADED IRAQ OR
ANYTHING.
WE WISH WE COULD TELL YOU IT WAS
JUST DEMOCRATS GETTING
HYSTERICAL BUT LYING IN THE
CONSERVATIVES ARE UNFORTUNATELY
BIPARTISAN.
THEN STAFF COME AT THE TOUGH GUY
REPUBLICAN REPRESENTS A STATE OF
NEBRASKA AND SAID HE WANTS TO
SEE THOSE DASTARDLY INTELLIGENT
AGENTS "IN BODY BAGS" KILL THEM,
KILL THEM ALL!
LIZ CHENEY OF WYOMING BY ANY
MEASURE TWICE THE MAN BEN SASSE
DEMANDED TO KNOW WHAT THE
PRESIDENT KNEW AND WHEN HE KNEW
IT.
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE IN RESPONSE
TO PROTECT OUR FORCES AND HOLD
VLADIMIR PUTIN ACCOUNTABLE, LIZ
CHENEY ASKED.
THE CABLE NEWS CHANNEL TURNED IT
UP TO 11.
THE HOUSE FOREIGN AFFAIRS
COMMITTEE HELD HEARINGS ON IT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY
DIDN'T SIMPLY BECAUSE POLITICAL
PROBLEMS FOR DONALD TRUMP,
THOUGH IT DID COMMIT CHANGE THE
FOREIGN POLICY OF THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
THERE IS PROFESSIONAL WINDBAG
SETH WHO GOT ELECTED TO THE
CONGRESSMAN OF MASSACHUSETTS
TELLING YOU HOW IMPORTANT THIS
IS.
>> NOW WE LEARNED THAT HE WAS
MAKING THIS DEAL AT THE SAME
TIME THERE WERE BOUNTIES ON THE
HEADS OF AMERICAN TROOPS.
AMERICANS SONS AND DAUGHTERS.
WE CLEARLY NEED MORE OVERSIGHT
OVER WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS DOING
IN AFGHANISTAN.
>> Tucker: SETH MOULTON SPEAK
SLOWLY BECAUSE HE THINKS SLOWLY.
BUT HE'S CLEAR ON ONE THING, WE
NEED MORE OVERSIGHT OVER
AFGHANISTAN.
AND THE CONGRESSMAN GOT IT.
JUST DAYS AFTER
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" STORY BOTH
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS ON THE
HEALTH SERVICES COMMITTEE VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY TO AMEND THE
ANNUAL DEFENSE BUDGET.
THEY DID THIS TO PREVENT THE
PRESIDENT, ANY PRESIDENT FROM
PULLING TROOPS OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
THAT IS THE ONE THING THE
PRESIDENTS ARE ALLOWED TO DO.
THAT AMENDMENT SPONSORED BY
JASON WHO IS A DEMOCRAT AND BY
LIZ CHENEY WHO IS A REPUBLICAN.
AND IT PASSED THE COMMITTEE BY A
VOTE OF 45-11.
IT BECAME LAW LATER IN THE YEAR.
AFTER THE SENATE OVERRODE
DONALD TRUMP'S VETO.
IT SEEMS TO RECALL THE ONLY VETO
THEY OVERRODE.
SO A NEW STORY WITH A SWIFTER OR
MORE PROFOUND EFFECT ON THIS ONE
DID.
BY NOW, YOU HAVE GUESSED THE
PUNCH LINE.
IT WAS FAKE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" WAS A LIE.
IT WAS PLACED IN THE PAPER BY
NEOCONS TO SUBVERT THE
DEMOCRATIC SYSTEM AND IT DID
APPEAR TO ONCE AGAIN IMPOSE
THEIR WILL ON THE COUNTRY.
THE REPUBLICANS DON'T WANT TO
STAY IN AFGHANISTAN FOR 20
YEARS, THEY DID AND GOT THEIR
WAY BECAUSE THEY LIED.
THE SO-CALLED INTEL COMMUNITY IS
ADMITTING THIS, THEY ADMIT THE
STORY WAS NOT TRUE AND DOING IT
FOR A SPECIFIC REASON.
JOE BIDEN DECIDED HE WANTS OUT
OF AFGHANISTAN, BUT BEFORE WE
CAN WITHDRAW THE TROOPS, WE NEED
NEW FACTS.
YOU HAVE TO FIX THE STORY OR YOU
CAN'T PULL THE TROOPS OUT AND
THE CIA IS HAPPY TO OBLIGE.
NONE OF IT IS REAL.
THEY CAN SAY THAT NOW.
BUT WHAT WE CAN'T DO WITH STOP
ATTACKING RUSSIA.
SO MAYBE RUSSIA DIDN'T ACTUALLY
PUT BOUNTIES ON OUR TROOPS, BUT
RUSSIA IS STILL VERY BAD.
RUSSIA, NOT CHINA, IS OUR CHIEF
ENEMY.
ADAM SCHIFF HOPEFULLY REMINDED
US OF THAT YESTERDAY.
>> THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY
SAYS THEY ONLY HAVE LOW TO
MODERATE CONFIDENCE THAT IT IS
AN ACCURATE STORY.
SO IT LOOKS AS THOUGH IN THIS
CASE, TRUMP MIGHT HAVE HAD THE
RIGHT RESPONSE, DON'T YOU SAY?
>> WELL, I DON'T THINK TRUMP HAD
THE RIGHT RESPONSE AND HE DIDN'T
CONFRONT THE RUSSIANS ON THIS.
HE DIDN'T APPEAR TO TAKE THE
ISSUE VERY SERIOUSLY.
YOU KNOW, IT IS MY SINCE THE
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY BELIEVES
THAT THE RUSSIANS DID ENGAGE IN
THIS CONDUCT BUT THEY DON'T HAVE
THE REQUISITE LEVEL OF
CONFIDENCE AND THAT CONCLUSION
TO GO FORWARD WITH SANCTIONS DO
MUCH SANCTIONS ON THAT BASIS.
>> Tucker: SO DONALD TRUMP
DIDN'T TAKE THE HOAX SERIOUSLY
ENOUGH AND THAT IS A SIGN OF BAD
CHARACTER.
WE DON'T KNOW THE RUSSIANS DID
ANYTHING WRONG, BUT WE MUST COME
FROM RUSSIA OVER WHAT WE DON'T
KNOW THEY DID ANYWAY.
SO ATTACK RUSSIA EVERY DAY.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW WHY WE ARE
DOING IT, THEY WILL KNOW PEER
THAT IS OUR NEW POSITION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
YESTERDAY DECLARED A NATIONAL
EMERGENCY FOR NO OBVIOUS REASON.
JOE BIDEN ANNOUNCED THAT RUSSIA
HAD SOMEHOW TAKEN MALIGNED
ACTIONS AGAINST U.S. INTERESTS.
WATCH.
>> TODAY, IN STEPS INCLUDING
SEVERAL RUSSIAN OFFICIALS AS A
CONSEQUENCE OF THEIR ACTIONS.
I HAVE ALSO SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER AUTHORIZING NEW MEASURES
WITH SANCTIONS TO ADDRESS
HARMFUL ACTIVITIES FOR THE
RUSSIANS TAKEN AGAINST
INTERESTS.
I WAS CLEAR THAT WE COULD NOT
HAVE GONE FURTHER.
BUT I CHOSE NOT TO DO SO.
I CHOSE TO BE PROPORTIONATE.
IF RUSSIA CONTINUES TO INTERFERE
WITH DEMOCRACY I AM PREPARED TO
TAKE FURTHER ACTIONS TO RESPOND.
>> Tucker: SAY THAT TAPE FOR
THE FUTURE WHEN YOU WANT A
REMINDER OF JUST HOW INSANE
THINGS GOT IN THE YEAR 2021.
THAT WASN'T POSTURING.
THAT WASN'T THEY WERE BAD.
THOSE ARE ACTIONS AGAINST A
SOVEREIGN NATION FOR EMPOWER
WITH EXPELLING DIPLOMATS,
DESTROYING THEIR ECONOMY AND
THREATENING TO BACK THEIR
ENEMIES IN A WAR, A REAL WORK
TOO COME NOT A WAR OF WORDS BUT
WHERE PEOPLE GET KILLED.
WE ARE DOING ALL OF THOSE
THINGS.
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHY ARE WE
DOING THAT?
THAT IS THE PART NOBODY
EXPLAINS.
THEY DON'T NEED TO BECAUSE
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS SO
UNBELIEVABLY HISTORICALLY
MONSTROUSLY EVIL, YOU DON'T NEED
A JUSTIFICATION TO GO A WAR
AGAINST HIM.
A MAN THAT BAD SHOULD BE
PUNISHED JUST FOR EXISTING WITH
NUCLEAR WEAPONS, IF NECESSARY.
HERE IS JOE BIDEN EXPLAIN TO
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS NO SOUL.
>> HE SAID YOU KNOW HE DOESN'T
HAVE A SOUL.
>> I DID SAY THAT TO HIM, I SAID
AND HIS RESPONSES WE UNDERSTAND
ONE ANOTHER.
THAT IS HOW IT CAME ABOUT.
WHEN PRESIDENT BUSH SAID I
LOOKED IN HIS EYES AND SAW HIS
SOUL.
I SAID, I LOOKED IN HIS EYES AND
I DON'T THINK HE HAD A SOUL.
AND HE LOOKED BACK AND SAID WE
UNDERSTAND EACH OTHER.
>> SO VLADIMIR PUTIN, YOU THINK
HE IS A KILLER?
>> I DO.
>> THAT IS TAKING FORM, CORN
POP TO A NEW LEVEL.
YOU DON'T HAVE A SOUL, DAEMON,
HUMAN GARGOYLE.
THIS IS A HEAD OF STATE.
WHO HAS OVER A THOUSAND NUCLEAR
WEAPONS AIMED AT US.
WHY DOES OUR PRESIDENT TALK
ABOUT RUSH OF THIS WAY?
WELL, IT IS OBVIOUS.
CLEARLY